[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you today great
cast of characters as well as always a
man who left behind journals in a coffee
shop and he did it on purpose what's
behind those Diaries we'll explain also
a U.S mail delivery driver who was
overcome with emotion after a stranger
stopped her on the street and volunteers
helping rescue 4 000 beagles plus a 70
year old who received a text alert
calling for help in her community and
what she did to step up and we're going
to take you to a chapel where 8 000
couples have tied the knot in a very
unconventional place where we'll tell
you plus meet the owner of a unique
coffee shop in Pennsylvania what makes
it so special we're going to explain all
that plus the heartwarming videos the
ones you gotta see you're watching The
Uplift
[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift the show
that lifts you up for at least the next
30 minutes you and me as well me being
Toyota good to see you glad to be with
you when was the last time you listed
the reasons that you were grateful to be
in this world well one man set out on a
mission to inspire others to express
their gratitude and they got a whole lot
in return David begno has a story
in coffee shops around the country
you might want to look out for a little
book titled today I am grateful for it's
there so that people in search of a
latte can also search their souls and
write a few words about what they are
grateful for
you coffee in New York City was the
first place the book showed up and it's
so simple it's just a few minutes every
day Teddy droceros who for 10 years has
written down what he is grateful for
every day thankful for the amazing
dinner I had with my brother put the
book in the coffee shop with the
permission of the owner so a story you
drop it off and then do you keep going
back to the coffee shop every day uh
yeah I check up on it and write myself
and what was it like seeing people
sitting there writing in it well that's
always an awesome experience like
because people would just take it and
bring it to their seat and just and just
read through it so explain to me what
the Gratitude Journal was going to be I
was just like oh this is just a tool
that I can leave around everywhere to
inspire people to practice gratitude
it didn't take long before the book
filled up and so another one was left
there I'm thankful for my pup my health
friends and Fam I'm grateful for living
room dance parties and non-sexual
intimacy
I love it and it Bird Rock Coffee in San
Diego California he put out more books
after he moved there so then how many
coffee shops did you end up giving books
to around the country I I actually don't
know my friends would help me out you
know when they were traveling they would
get books out there and then I started
getting random emails from strangers
saying hey I saw this in this coffee
shop can we bring it to my neighborhood
he calls his project grateful peoples
and a lot of that gratitude comes right
back to him after the books are all
filled up how many of them came back at
least 100 I would say so when you got
your first book back and you went
through it how was that I noticed that
when I would feel down I would go pick
up one of the filled up books I
collected it would like instant make me
feel better
Teddy droceros by his own admission was
not always a grateful person and
that when he comes here where he watched
his mother's ashes flow into the Pacific
Ocean what did she have she was
diagnosed with multiple sclerosis when I
was a baby but it eventually passed from
cancer
's illness robbed him of a normal
childhood and it left him bitter he says
my experience with her and her sickness
you know Ms impacts the brain and
changes behavior and personality and it
was difficult it was kind of hard to be
grateful for it at the time but and the
thing with why I became so passionate
about gratitude and started grateful
peoples because the more time I took to
write in this journal I realized that
everything I was experiencing with my
mom was seriously my biggest blessing
I'll probably ever have do you have your
first entry uh yeah
February 29 2012. I'm thankful I was
born healthy into a great family with
all Limbs and able to do everything I
was able to as a child playing all those
Sports growing up was a blessing if you
need a fresh Journal now schools have
teamed up with grateful peoples because
Teddy droceros has distributed 20 000
books to school children grateful for my
father I am grateful for how education
changed how I spoken how I wrote I'm
grateful for my little brother doing
good in school it turns out that
gratitude can foster more gratitude and
people actually want to read about it so
you ended up writing a book and the book
was written with the entries of all
kinds of people yeah it was just like a
like a collection of gratitude thoughts
and what'd you call the book today I'm
grateful for and how many entries about
a thousand did you read every one of
those in the book so I collected 75 000
entries and I read through every single
one which was a blessing because it was
just like 75 000 bits of perspective
somewhere in those 75 000 entries was
one that said Deanna and today remains
part of the legacy of Deanna Mondello a
dancer who died Too Young at 28 years
old in a car crash
when someone passes you kind of you want
to collect everything in every memory
and everything that they touched and
wrote Jen Freeman a fellow dancer was
among the people who knew that a
gratitude book at that Astoria coffee
shop held a link to her friend Deanna so
I went to the coffee shop and I asked
who was responsible for these journals
and they put me in touch with Teddy did
Deanna seem to you to be a person of
gratitude yes and that is what is really
beautiful and sort of serendipitous
about
this whole connection coming together
hearing about Deanna was sort of a
catalyst for him to actually embark on
this journey of creating this book makes
so much sense to me because that was the
way she lived her life like she always
was expressing her gratitude and Teddy's
own mother just before she died wrote on
July 11 2019.
she wrote I'm grateful to be alive just
knowing where my mom was when she wrote
that the fact that she was able to just
think and feel that way is special to me
and
that's why I love this journal and I'll
have it with me forever I got a piece of
my mom here
[Music]
I first left that gratitude book at that
right now
I'm a new one these days and more often
than not about his mother
the more you lose the more I gain as
your illness took away the simple things
it made me realize how lucky I am to
have them I'm not sure I'd understand
how lucky I am to tie my own shoes if I
didn't have to tie yours when you
couldn't do it anymore but gratitude
taught me it only makes sense to love
something I can't change it's the
inspiration behind everything I do
I just had a big aha moment
gratitude taught me to love something I
cannot change yeah that that's what
gratitude does it just it allows you to
shift your perspective of what already
is like I can't change that my mom was
sick but I can look at it as a blessing
or I can look at it as something dark
but my relationship with her is the best
it's ever been it really is
even though she's long gone it continues
yeah for sure I'm more connected to her
now than I ever was
that's a pretty story there and if that
book were in front of you it's worth
asking yourselves today what would you
write in it
all right we're going to move on to our
next story it takes us to a cafe outside
of Philadelphia and it's located in fact
inside a record store and that is not
the only thing that makes it unique
Caitlin O'Kane has our story
bringing someone a cup of coffee is a
simple act that can show them just how
much you care Jacob McFarland loved
bringing his dad coffee before he went
to work at his record store for Jacob it
was an act of kindness and a passion it
makes you feel very very happy it really
does I'm telling you the truth it
totally does she's telling me the truth
Jacob is his father's uh biggest fan and
my husband loves coffee so everything
that my husband loves Jacob loves I
didn't know though that Jacob was
immersing himself in all types of
research about the proper beans to use
the different coffee Blends the best
water the water temperature the
technology of the whole thing I didn't
know any of that I'm sorry the milk
Jacob who has autism and ADHD became
known as Barista Jake around the house
Jake's mom Angela says that nickname
became known around their community in
Norristown Pennsylvania when the
pandemic happened and our lives all came
to a screeching halt
um the record store wasn't open Jacob
couldn't go to school he craves routine
and and he didn't have a routine anymore
because of the pandemic so we decided to
do a curbside coffee cart outside of our
store what that turned into was an
overwhelming Community
appreciation of Jacob and knowing that
he was living his dream of being Barista
Jake running the car not only brought
people together over coffee during the
pandemic it brought Jacob Joy
the car eventually moved inside the
record store and the coffee closet with
Barista Jake expanded
make the hot coffee we watched a video
and learn how to do iced coffee and then
we got our license to start serving food
so we did we do breakfast stuff it just
has been a whirlwind ever since the
person that Jacob is now the fact that
you asked the question and he jumped
right in with the answer that never
would have happened two years ago and
now Jake's business employs other young
people with disabilities we just want
this to be a safe place for these people
to come in feel of service and of value
learn some vocational skills I also help
them with resume
design and preparation we'll do mock
interviews we're eventually going to
have a little storage facility where
they can get interview attire so that
these kids can get ready to go out and
interview and put their best foot
forward and for Jacob his role as head
Barista has been life-changing
while he
had
he's never had a sleepover he's never
gone on vacation with a friend he's
never brought a friend on vacation he
didn't have sort of some of those
experiences and now you know when I hear
him having very
very organic casual conversations with
his co-workers and you know they're
high-fiving and hey good to see you
buddy I can't tell you what that does to
me because I never thought that he would
have that and he's he has really
um he's making his way the coffee closet
isn't just a family business it's a
welcoming place for all and a legacy for
Jacob I think he feels like he has a
purpose and
um he gets really excited to come to
work and he will see certain people he
knows their car and he'll start making
their coffee before they've even come
out you know walked in the door he's
found the social side of himself and if
if this were all to go away tomorrow the
advancement in Jacob in two and a half
years has been worth everything
thank you
Jacob loves his coffee according to the
T-shirt I think people love Jacob's
coffee as well uh he's more than just uh
Barista Jake he's head Barista quite a
title looks like pretty good stuff all
right coming up meet the fleet of
volunteers and workers helping to rescue
thousands of beagles who had an unfair
start to life plus our heartwarming
videos including this one what brought
this postal worker to tears find out
after the break
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift it is that
time we're going to do it time for those
heartwarming videos the ones you got to
see and we're going to begin with this
one
[Applause]
that is a dad named Gallo getting a big
surprise on birthday number 60. his
daughter told us here at the uplift that
he is the youngest of one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten siblings
so for his big day they flew in every
single one of them hope they got a group
rate they were all born and raised in
Quito Ecuador but they now all live here
in these United States and his siblings
flew from to Chicago rather from Texas
from Mexico City from Atlanta from New
York Florida Pennsylvania I could go on
they all just wanted to be there to wish
their little brother happy birthday 60
is a big one all right our next video
shows the impact a random act of
kindness can have take a look
what's your name Debbie Debbie I'm
Isaiah Isaiah I'm trying to get some
extra change to get home on the bus I
wanted to see if you possibly had like
an extra dollar or two
are you serious yeah here take it grab
it can I ask you why you were willing to
do that though why
please help people I'm actually doing
this thing today
where I'm surprising the first person
who gives me money for the bus with
three hundred dollars
I have some money for you are you
that is funny you give some you get a
lot in that case it all comes back very
sweet moment there
all right to another sweet moment
another video this is a moment between a
dad his name is Mike Jackson and his
three-year-old daughter her name is
Harper
come on I got you
ready we're gonna count to three and you
go okay ready
why
one two
three
go go go
I got you
yes you can yes you can
just go Daddy got you say there's
nothing there's nothing that I I can't
do
when I
do it do it let's go one two three go
yeah
the high pressure catch but Dad does it
that's some great father in there well
done Mr Jackson all right thousands of
dogs in our next story got a devastating
start to life but they're getting a new
lease on that life where they started
and where they're going next that story
is coming up
Liberty rolled who answered the call to
help her community what old job did she
come back to we'll tell you stay with us
when thousands of dogs in a dire
situation needed rescuing the helpers
turned out in droves here's Manuel
bojorkes with the story
here we go they arrive here nervous
sometimes sick often hungry and always
into new experiences having their feet
on the grass for the first time ever the
first time ever first time ever these
dogs have not touched the surface that
hasn't been rubber since they were born
you're seeing them getting to run and
hop they've never done that before Sue
Bell is executive director of homework
Trails adoption center in Fairfax
Station Virginia a code tattooed inside
the dog's ears a sad reminder of their
recent past the puppies that were born
they would stay until a certain age and
then be put in plastic crates and sent
either by truck or by airplane to
research facilities where they would
then spend their life in a cage
undergoing any number of medical or
scientific research projects
but the research company breeding them
shut this operation down now an army of
workers and volunteers is helping the
Humane Society move the dogs to shelters
across the country 4 000 beagles as they
arrive at Sue Bell's adoption center so
did the dog lovers like Andrea Justice
we don't need more dogs you know we have
two but we have plenty of room in our
hearts in our house another new
experience being part of a loving home
look at that first time on grass to our
next story back to school time it can
mean a lot of money spent on new
supplies and clothes and not every
family can afford it so one organization
is making sure that kids are prepared
one backpack at a time Meg Oliver now
has more
a lot of times I ride on the back of the
card you got this because they just need
to know that someone's in their corner
and someone's fighting for them words of
encouragement from the team at
Volunteers of America
in New York City before school starts
operation backpack will distribute more
than fifteen thousand new bags for every
homeless student anti-niblet helps
deliver them our goal is to have
children be able to move out into the
world with a feeling of confidence and
possibility the backpack is a small way
to start that children like six-year-old
Kyle Gregory how does it feel when you
put this on
you feel fast and strong when you put
this on Kyle and his mom Crystal have
been living in a shelter for the past
three years she still remembers Kyle's
sweet smile after receiving that first
backpack it was heartwarming I actually
cried a little bit because who wouldn't
ever thought Us in the predicament that
we are that we're actually receive
something from someone you know what I'm
saying and caring about my child so it
really meant a lot
an act of kindness trying to break the
cycle of poverty one superhero backpack
at a time
oh it's a nice piece that backpack means
a lot coming up the woman returning to a
job she had at 15 because she wants to
help her community what job is it we
will tell you plus we're gonna go to a
chapel that has held thousands of
weddings despite its unusual location do
we have a guess we'll tell you who's
right after the break
foreign
wedding you may think of a roadside
Chapel in Las Vegas I certainly did but
the little chapel in Bloomington
Minnesota is somehow even less
traditional than that CBS Minnesota's
Kirsten Mitchell has more
you know at first I went oh my that's
really odd
it's a common reaction to seeing a
wedding chapel inside the Mall of
America before I purchased it I actually
came in and sat in on a wedding and
realized that it's no different than a
wedding anywhere else it's just in a
very unconventional location how many
people do hold in here 35. Felicia glass
Wilcox found it was the perfect space
for the more than 8 000 couples who
chose to marry at the chapel of Love
since it opened in 1994. second
marriages military couples
um you know people who don't have a
budget for a wedding to be able to
provide a service that is nice intimate
and more about the couple that's why
High School sweethearts sephra and
Denzel decided to tie the knot Tuesday
after 11 years together what's nice
about having a chapel here is very
convenient very cozy as well like it's
just really nice we can keep it really
personal just with us and our friends
and make that more special for us over
the years Felicia has seen it at all and
as witness history marrying one of the
state's first same-sex couples at
midnight the day it became legal in
Minnesota when that happened it became a
very personal business because I was
proud of it I was so proud of the fact
that I was able to do something that I
felt should have been done years ago
just as times changed so the challenges
of running a business Chapel of love
will close at the end of the month and
Felicia will retire but not before
taking a moment to remember all of the
people she's had the pleasure to meet
and marry along the way I just want to
thank them it was it means a lot to me
oh I'm sure it means a lot to them as
well all that matters is I do and a lot
of them happen right there all right to
our final story it's about a 70 year old
who saw that her community needed help
so she returned to a job she first had
when she was just 15 years old CBS
Boston's Rachel Holt picks up the story
a text alert in June pleading for the
community's help we need staff you know
in order to keep our facility open we
need help at the time YMCA Cape Cod was
forced to close its small pool due to a
staffing shortage I'm retired so I have
time Barnstable grandmother Maggie
Sullivan was one of the first people to
respond her only hesitation her
lifeguard certification had expired 50
years ago she heard the call and she
decided to come and help out we got her
certified and hey things have changed
but it was pretty easy to study up and
get back on board with it the 70 year
old former teacher is now working at the
Y as a lifeguard and swim instructor
try it again she recognizes the ability
of each kid and she adjusts what she's
doing to them Maggie first gained
lifeguarding experience here at calamus
beach in Barnstable where she started
out as a junior lifeguard at the age of
15. and worked her way up to head
lifeguard in the 60s and 70s it was a
great job I did it until I graduated
from college her co-workers at the Y are
mostly in their 20s an age difference
that's proven to have its benefits but
like let's go to dinner it's five
o'clock
so I'm fresh I'm rested and but the
young people offer things to me as well
their energy their alertness we get
older sometimes you know we lose our way
and we have to understand that we have
talent and it's great to share that
talent and I am so glad that Meg decided
to share her town with us
nice note to end on and what a show it
was I hope it brightens your day I hope
it lifted you up but you know what if it
didn't for any reason at all we got a
money back guarantee you can re-watch
the uplift anytime that is our show
we'll see you again soon I'm gonna go
look for some more good stories